I get it you didn't get your fill of  spine ripping and Skull Crushing for  mortal kombat x and you want more  luckily there's a new version of the  game on its way Mortal Kombat XL in  addition to the clever name it's packing  a ton of content some zero wins fatality  XL edition includes all characters from  combat pack 1 and 2 that's Jason  Voorhees predator tanya tremor  Leatherface xenomorph oh right show and  try board it also includes Goro who was  originally a pre-order bonus and don't  forget about skin packs like samurai and  cold war scorpion you'll get all five of  those two mortal kombat x el edition  launches for ps4 and xbox one on march  first you can pick up the retail disc or  download it digitally we gave the  original release an 8 out of 10 last  year so visit gamespot to check out the  full review and for all the fatalities  and brutalities you want you'll already  be in the right place